Man redet immer so viel drüber, kann
ich Selbstmord möglichst schmerzfrei machen
oder sowas. Ich finde, es sollte
viel mehr Wert darauf gelegt werden,
-den zu verhindern.
-Wir starten jetzt mit der wichtigsten
Frage dieser Diskussion und mit der ersten
Frage von 13 Fragen. Sollte jeder Mensch
ein Recht auf organisierte Sterbehilfe
haben? Wenn ihr jetzt sagt: Ja, dann geht
ihr einen Schritt ins grüne
Kästchen. Und wenn ihr sagt: Nein, nicht jeder
oder keiner, dann geht ihr einen
Schritt ins gelbe Kästchen. Habt ihr euch schon
mal mit dem Thema Sterbehilfe
befasst? Das Ding ist nämlich, rund 100.000
Menschen versuchen sich jährlich in Deutschland
umzubringen. Ungefähr 10.000
Menschen von denen sterben am Ende
tatsächlich. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat jetzt beschlossen, in Deutschland
hat jeder Mensch einen Anspruch
auf Sterbehilfe, egal ob kerngesund
oder schwer krank. Doch wer entscheidet final,
ob jemand sterben darf oder nicht?
Darüber diskutieren wir heute hier bei 13 Fragen.
Und für euch heißt das ab jetzt, wenn ihr einer Aussage
der anderen Seite zustimmt,
dann geht ihr einen Schritt auf sie zu.
Und wenn ihr der Aussage nicht zustimmt
oder richtig sauer seid und dieser Wut
Ausdruck verleihen wollt, dann geht
ihr einen Schritt zurück. Und ich will
heute natürlich, das ist mein Ziel,
euch möglichst weit ins Kompromissfeld
bringen. Deswegen umso mehr ihr euch
bewegt, umso besser für mich. Brigitte,
ich möchte mit dir gerne anfangen. Du bist
ja Mitglied in einem
Sterbehilfe-Verein. In was für einem Moment kommt man
auf den Gedanken "da
trete ich jetzt mal ein"?
Das ist bei mir eine ganz
persönliche Erfahrung. Und zwar hat das mit meiner
Mutter zu tun, die vor drei Jahren
einen sehr, sehr schlimmen Sturz hatte.
Und es kam dann so, dass sie nach sechs
Wochen querschnittsgelähmt war.
Als 89-jährige Frau, die ihr ganzes
Leben lang selbstständig war bis zu dem Sturz,
konnte sie das nicht
verkraften. Sie wollte sterben. Außerdem hatte
sie Schmerzen, die offenbar
nicht therapierbar waren. Und ich habe
ihr vorgeschlagen, in ihrer
Verzweiflung, dass ich sie, wenn sie das möchte,
in die Schweiz begleite zur Sterbehilfe.
Ich denke, dass es eine Anmaßung ist,
über das Leben eines anderen Menschen
zu bestimmen. Jeder Mensch hat das Recht,
über sein Leben und seinen Tod selbst
zu bestimmen. Ja, ich bin dann mit meiner
Mutter zusammen in diesen Verein
eingetreten. Meine Mutter ist
ohne Sterbehilfe verstorben damals,
die Zeit hat uns überholt. Ich bin aber drin
geblieben, weil ich das für mich
auch sehr wichtig finde, das eventuell
-gegebenenfalls in Anspruch zu nehmen.
-Mich würde auch total interessieren, wie
seht ihr das eigentlich? Ist euch das wichtig,
diese Option zu haben, euren Tod
selbst bestimmen zu können? Schreib
es mal in die Kommentare. Ihr steht jetzt
auf der anderen Seite. Wollt ihr euch
dazu positionieren? Würdet ihr einen Schritt
-auf Brigitte zugehen?
-Die Frage ist halt, ob es ein Recht auf
Organisationen gibt, die sozusagen
einem beim Suizid assistieren. Und das heißt ja,
dass jeder dieses Recht in jeder
Situation annehmen kann. Das Verfassungsgericht hat
ja auch keine neue Rechtslage
geschaffen, sondern nur klargestellt,
was unsere Rechtslage ist und auch immer
hier war vor 2015, nämlich dass Suizid
bei uns straffrei ist. Anders als in den Niederlande
oder Österreich, da ist
die Beihilfe zum Suizid eine Straftat
und dass jeder jedem auch dabei helfen darf.
Wir haben eben nur nicht oder das wollte
der Gesetzgeber mit diesem Paragraph 217
unterbinden, der wollte ja
nirgends Selbstbestimmung einschränken,
sondern wollte Menschen schützen vor sehr unseriösen
Sterbehelfern, die wir hier
hatten. Bei Sterbehilfe-Organisationen,
die eben geschäftsmäßig professionell
Beihilfe zum Suizid oder dann
vielleicht irgendwann auch Tötung auf Verlangen
anbieten, sehe ich einmal die große
Gefahr, dass eben bei Patienten
oder Menschen, die eine Sterbewunsch
äußern, nicht wirklich gut geschaut wird,
ob da vielleicht was anderes
dahinter steht, ob es eher auch darum geht,
-so nicht mehr leben zu wollen.
-Philipp, du möchtest nicht selbst
entscheiden, wann du stirbst, also
quasi genau der Kontrast zu Brigitte. Warum?
Wenn man sich die Frage stellt,
woher das Leben kommt, hab ich einfach krasse
Erfahrungen gemacht, dass es da vielleicht
doch jemanden gibt, der uns das Leben
gegeben hat und dass wir nicht
die Berechtigung haben zu sagen: Okay,
das Leben ist jetzt vorbei. Ich habe
selber einen Tumor auf der Brust und mir
haben schon ganz viele Leute
vorgeschlagen, dass ich ja auch mir
Gedanken machen sollte, ob ich eventuell
Sterbehilfe in Anspruch nehmen soll.
Ich bin aber der Meinung, dass das Leben
dann vorbei ist, wann Gott es will.
Weil ich glaube, dass es jemand gibt,
der uns geschaffen hat und der auch einen Plan
für uns hat und der das auch in die Hand
nehmen sollte, wann das Leben vorbei ist.
Also es ist meine dritte
Krebsdiagnose. Die letzten Male konnte ich kaum laufen.
Ich war einfach mental überhaupt
nicht fit. Und diesmal geht es mir gut.
Kannst du dich noch an den Moment
erinnern, wo du die Diagnose bekommen
-hast? Wie hast du darauf reagiert?
-Da war ich in einem dunklen Zimmer mit
einem Arzt und einem
Computerbildschirm. Und da bin ich in so ein krasses Loch
gefallen, ich wusste gar nicht
wirklich, was Krebs ist und habe mich irgendwie
an meine Nachbarin erinnert. Eine alte
Frau, die hat Krebs gehabt und ich kriege
das jetzt. Und ich wusste überhaupt
nicht mehr weiter. Also für mich ist die Welt so
zusammengebrochen. Ich konnte
damit gar nicht umgehen.
Und du sagst quasi, deswegen bist du
gegen einen selbstbestimmten Tod zumindest
bei dir, weil du dein Leben dann
vielleicht sogar schon beendet hättest
und man das nie genau wissen
kann, wie so eine Krankheit verläuft.
Danach sogar, bei meiner zweiten
Krebsdiagnose hieß es auch, meine Mutter
soll lieber den Leichenwagen holen als den Krankenwagen,
weil es mir so schlecht
geht. Ich hab die Zeit auch teilweise
ausgeblendet, weil es mir wirklich so
schlecht ging. Da hätte ich wahrscheinlich
schon Sterbehilfe in Anspruch nehmen
können, vielleicht sogar in dem Moment
zugestimmt, wenn's die Optionen gegeben
hätte. Und jetzt stehe ich hier,
das ist drei Jahre her und mir geht's gut.
Und mein Arzt sagt: Was ist da passiert,
wie bist du wieder fit geworden?
Und von daher sehe ich schon, es gibt
da noch mehr zwischen Himmel und Erde.
Was sagt ihr dazu, würdet ihr einen
Schritt auf Philipp zugehen?
-Ja.
-Erik, du bist stehen geblieben.
Ich verstehe deine Worte und die berühren
einen natürlich total. Aber ich glaube,
die größte Gefahr ist da quasi, dass du
deine Perspektive für andere einnimmst.
Ich erlebe jeden Tag in meiner Arbeit,
was es mit Menschen macht, wenn sich kranke
Menschen das Leben nehmen müssen,
weil sie keinen anderen Ausweg sehen
und von der Medizin keine Hilfe
bekommen. Ich sehe quasi die Opfer des Suizids
neben den Verstorbenen. So wie man dir
das Recht dazu eingesteht, das zu machen,
finde ich, darf es auch die Antwort
geben, die auf der anderen Seite ist, nämlich
zu sagen: Nee, ich habe für mich
alles ausgeschöpft, was da ist. Und wie Leiden
dort wahrgenommen wird, ist halt
etwas sehr Relatives. Und ich denke, da ist
die persönliche
Freiheit einfach höher zu bewerten.
-Stimmst du dem zu? Du nickst.
-Teilweise. Also ich kann es mega gut
verstehen, wenn man irgendwie die Erfahrungen
nicht macht und dann gar
nichts damit anfangen kann, wenn man
selber nie in der Situation war
und es nicht erlebt hat. Trotzdem
glaube ich halt, es ist für mich grundsätzlich so
ein bisschen die Frage: Wer entscheidet
über Leben und Tod, geht es nach dem Leben
auch weiter? Und ich sehe ganz klar
die Gefahr: Also bei mir z.B. war es so,
dass ich fast eine palliative
Chemo gemacht hätte - wo jetzt gerade sogar
die deutsche Ärztezeitung
geschrieben hat, das macht keinen Sinn -
nur weil meine Freunde gesagt haben
"Ja, probier es doch aus und so". Und ich sehe
eine ganz große Gefahr, dass man
unter Druck gesetzt wird, Sterbehilfe
in Anspruch zu nehmen, nur weil ich mich
z.B. als Last empfinde. Ich wäre auf jeden
Fall so ein Mensch, ich will es immer
allen recht machen. Ich würde dann glaube
ich, im Zweifelsfall vielleicht
sogar sagen: "Ja okay, ich nehme es jetzt
in Anspruch" und da so die Grenze zu kriegen,
ist mega schwierig, glaub ich.
Das finde ich auch. Gerade das, was du
sagst, dass es was Individuelles ist.
Ist es da nicht umso gefährlicher,
eine Normierung herzustellen, wo wir sagen,
da gibt's dann die Vereine, die das Patentrezept
anbieten? Und zu dem Thema
Selbstbestimmung: Ich finde, dass dieser Begriff
in dieser Diskussion teilweise
völlig skurril verwendet wird,
weil wir leben in sozialen Gemeinschaften
und da sind wir weit entfernt
davon, selbstbestimmt zu leben. Die Rentnerin
mit 800 Euro Rente, die kann
nicht einmal entscheiden selbstbestimmt,
ob sie Veganerin sein will oder nicht,
weil sie's nicht bezahlen kann.
Wenn wir über den Tellerrand
Deutschlands gucken und sehen, wo die Würde verletzt
wird, ist das ganz anders. Das würdige
Leben und das Selbstbestimmte wäre ja erst
-schon mal ein Ziel.
-Du hast einen ganz wichtigen Punkt dabei:
Verantwortung anderen gegenüber. Und die wird
auch darin dann getragen zu sagen:
"Wenn ich gehe, versuche ich es so
angenehm wie möglich für mein Umfeld
zu machen." Weil egal welche
Regelung besteht, es wird ja dennoch der Suizid
-im stillen Kämmerlein durchgeführt.
-Erik, du hast Heiner gerade zugestimmt,
also kannst du einen Schritt auf ihn
zugehen. Welche Vorteile kann denn
da eine legale,
organisierte Sterbehilfe haben?
Ganz großer Treiber von einem
ungesunden Trauerprozess ist schlechtes Gewissen.
Ich kann letzte Wünsche nicht
erfüllen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie ich reagieren
würde bei uns - nicht auf Arbeit,
sondern persönlich - wenn meine Oma, 85, zu mir
sagt: "Eric, hier ist jetzt Schluss,
bitte hilf mir dabei." Also entweder lehne
ich den Wunsch von ihr ab, komme quasi
in eine Loyalitätsfalle oder ich mache es,
dann habe ich einen Menschen
umgebracht. In die Situation möchte ich niemanden
bringen. Und viel wichtiger noch was ich in meiner
Arbeit sehe, ist der psychische
Schaden den Suizide - die eben dann
die Antwort sind, wenn ich keine medizinische
Hilfe bekomme, in dem Maße, wie ich sie brauche
- was ein Suizid auslöst
in einer Familie, im Familiensystem,
ist ein immenser Schaden ein immenses
-Traumata.
-Hast du denn da ein konkretes Beispiel, wo
es genau so eine Situation gab, wo du
gesagt hättest: Naja, bei den Angehörigen
wäre vielleicht in dem Fall
Sterbehilfe, hätte die ganze Situation das Trauern
-besser gemacht.
-Ich habe zwei Extrembeispiele für mich,
die aber durchaus beispielhaft
sind. Das es für mich was anderes ist -
und das machen wir bei unserer
Arbeit - Kinder darauf vorzubereiten,
dass ein Elternteil stirbt. Das kann
passieren bei einer Krebserkrankung.
Wenn für dieses Elternteil aber dann
die Antwort des gewalttätigen Suizides ist,
ist der Schaden bei den Kindern
meines Erachtens signifikant größer,
als wenn die psychologisch
betreut auf diesen Prozess vorbereitet sind.
Und das Zweite, wo ich selber immer
wieder in die Situation komme, ist wie häufig
Menschen bei mir sitzen, die eine infaust
Diagnose haben, die mir relativ deutlich
sagen, wann sie sterben werden. Wo einfach
klar ist, was für ein Weg da vor denen
liegt, dass sie das für sich selber
entschieden haben, aber die dann immer
damit kämpfen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob sich
jemand an den Autor von Tschick erinnert,
den Herrndorf, der mit einer Krebsdiagnose
beschreibt, der sich das Leben nehmen
möchte und dessen größte Angst ist:
Wo schieße ich eigentlich hin, um wirklich
tot zu sein? Und nochmal: Es gibt die Suizide.
Du hast die Zahlen vorhin gesagt
und die werden wir auch nicht
verhindern. Die Frage ist: Können wir die in eine Bahn
lenken, dass es fürs Umfeld und für den,
der sich das Leben nimmt,
-ertragbarer wird?
-Ich würde gern nochmal darauf
zurückkommen, dass du, Philipp,
vorhin gesagt hast, dass du auch schon Momente
hattest, wo du irgendwie einen
Druck verspürt hast. Eine Frage an euch,
könnte die Liberalisierung der Sterbehilfe
nicht auch tatsächlich zu solchen
Situationen für führen? Dass Menschen
z.B. alte Menschen, die dann irgendwie Angst
haben, dass sie ihrer Familie
emotional sowie finanziell zur Last fallen,
sich unter Druck fühlen und dann
irgendwie denken, dass ist jetzt ein Mittel,
-was da raus führen würde?
-Ich würde sagen, man muss das ganze
Prozedere in irgendeiner Form
standardisieren, wenn man den Begriff mal
benutzen darf. Es kann
natürlich nicht sein, dass irgendjemand
zu einer SterbehilfeOrganisation geht
und sagt: Ich habe die Nase voll, ich möchte
gerne nächste Woche sterben. Es muss
schon bestimmte Hürden geben. Und der Suizident
muss natürlich berücksichtigen, dass auf der anderen
Seite Leute stehen, die keinen
Fehler machen wollen und jemanden
einfach in den Tod schicken. Das ist ja eine ganz
klare Sache. Ich könnte mir
vorstellen - vielleicht gibt's das auch zum Teil,
keine Ahnung - dass man einen
Fragebogen ausarbeitet, mit viel Empathie,
patientenorientiert, mit ganz
großer Feinfühligkeit, den man
mit dem Suizidenten durchgeht. Und zwar
in Anwesenheit eines Arztes und vielleicht
auch noch eines Psychologen,
eines Wunschmenschen, wenn man das will,
sodass man wirklich am Ende sicher
sein kann, dass derjenige eben nicht gedrängt
wurde. Und ich glaube, man kann schon
dann ein Gespür dafür bekommen, ob derjenige
vielleicht doch noch lieber leben
würde, wenn die Umstände denn anders wären.
Oder eben sagt: Nein, es ist gut
nicht gemeint, aber ich möchte nicht -
Wie wäre es dann für dich, wenn das jetzt
einfach eine normale Option wäre, würde so
ein Test für dich
helfen, so ein Fragebogen?
Nee, gar nicht. Ich muss da ganz
sagen, wenn ich jetzt den Druck von außen
verspüren würde, dass ich zum Beispiel
meiner Familie nicht mehr länger zur Last
fallen möchte, dann würde ich natürlich
den Fragebogen auch genauso ausfüllen.
Ich bin ja nicht dumm, dass ich am Ende
halt die Sterbehilfe genehmigt bekomme.
Ich glaube, dass dieser Druck, auch wenn man
da eine Frage stellt und sagt "Ist
da dieser Druck da?" und das vielleicht
auch psychologisch hinterfragt. Ich war
auch schon bei vielen Psychologen
gewesen, auch während der ersten Therapie,
wo es mir nicht gut ging. Die sie sind
nicht auf den Grund gekommen, warum es mir
-eigentlich nicht gut gehen und so.
-Also ich kann mich natürlich nur
reinfühlen in deine Situation, aber ich habe
sie noch nie erlebt. Hast du manchmal
den Moment gehabt, wo du dachtest:
Oh, das ist so scheiße für meine Familie,
dass die sich gerade um mich kümmern
müssen und ich merke, dass sie da drunter
-leiden?
-Ja, tatsächlich. Weil ich ich bin halt
voll der lebensfrohe Mensch, ich würde
nie auf die Idee kommen, Selbsmord machen
zu wollen. Aber es war wirklich
teilweise so, gerade bei meinen Freunden,
die einfach mit der Situation nicht
umgehen konnten, dass ich wirklich gedacht
haben: Ich wäre lieber einfach nicht
mehr da. Das war für mich voll die Qual,
auch meine Freunde dann zu sehen, die haben
mehr gelitten als ich. Und das hat
-mir mega zu schaffen gemacht.
-Könnt ihr das irgendwie verstehen, dass
das zumindest für ihn persönlich in solchen
Momenten nicht gerade das Beste
-gewesen wäre, wenn das standardisiert ist?
-Das ist doch sozusagen das Schlimmste, was
einem passieren kann. Also da muss man
doch glaube ich nicht drüber diskutieren,
-dass das -
-Aber es ist nicht realistisch, dass das
auch noch viel häufiger
passiert, gerade bei alten Menschen?
Ja, das ist immer diese Projektion
in die Zukunft, die natürlich keiner heute
mit Gewissheit beantworten kann. Und das war
ja auch im Urteil ganz klar zu lesen,
dass das Gericht gesagt hat: Sehr wohl
hat der Staat die Pflicht, diese Umstände
zu prüfen, um eben zu verhindern,
dass Menschen aus solchen Zwängen heraus sich
vielleicht - oder gerade auf die Altenheime
bezogen - gedrängt fühlen.
Da würde ich natürlich auch mal die Frage
stellen: Wie gehen wir mit unseren alten
Menschen um? Was sind das für Rahmenbedingungen,
von denen wir jetzt
sagen, die sind so gravierend, dass sie dazu
führen könnten, dass hier so eine Art
-sozialer Druck aufgebaut wird?
-Wir leben im Kapitalismus, das wissen wir.
Ist es nicht auch irgendwie
realistisch, wenn man mal so in die Zukunft schaut,
dass so ein Moment passieren könnte,
dass vielleicht auch der Staat sagt: Na ja,
Palliativmedizin ist zu teuer, alte
Menschen gehen eh nicht mehr arbeiten,
-dann halt Sterbehilfe. Ist das nicht was -
-Na klar, das ist auf jeden Fall die
kostengünstigste Variante, das letzte
Lebensjahr ist unglaublich teuer.
Das wissen die Kassen auch. Und nur was du
gesagt hast, im Verfassungsurteil steht
das Gegenteil drin. Da steht nämlich,
dass wenn Menschen sagen "ich möchte niemanden
zur Last fallen", dass das ein Grund
ist, der zu akzeptieren ist. Es wird nirgends
gesagt, der Staat muss, sondern der Staat
kann überprüfen Freiverantwortlichkeit,
Dauerhaftigkeit und Ernsthaftigkeit
eines Suizids und allein bei freiverantwortlich
wird's schon schwierig. Wie freiverantwortlich
bin ich, wenn mir Tag
ein, Tag aus klar gemacht wird,
mein Leben ist nichts mehr wert, ich bin
ein Kostenfaktor. Und wenn ich Alternativen
nicht weiß, dann ist
das mit der Freiverantwortlichkeit
nicht so weit hergeholt. Das sind alles unklare
Begriffe, wo tatsächlich diese Normalisierung
und gerade Standardisierung
erschreckt mich dann eher, wenn die Leute
im Altenheim das schon ankreuzen,
ab welchem Status
sie dann nicht mehr wollen.
Brigitte, ohne dass du Heiner jetzt
in allen Punkten irgendwie zustimmen musst,
-verstehst du diesen einen Punkt?
-Ich kann hier im Grunde alle Punkte
verstehen, aber irgendwie komme ich immer
wieder auf einen Punkt zurück. Egal
wie richtig oder falsch das alles
sein mag, ein Mensch hat das Recht, für sich
selbst zu entscheiden. Ich habe für mich
selbst beschlossen, ich werde niemals
in ein Seniorenheim gehen, in ein Pflegeheim,
denn ich lass mir
meine Freiheit nicht nehmen. Und da hat
kein Mensch irgendwas mitzureden und mir
das zu versuchen auszureden, weil ich würde
dann sagen: Alles gut gemeint,
dankeschön, aber
habe ich keine Lust drauf.
-Nora, verstehst du das?
-Ich kann es verstehen, dass man das
möchte, aber ich finde es nicht
richtig. Da spielt aber auch mein christlicher
Glaube eine Rolle. Dass ich denke, ich als Mensch
sollte darüber nicht urteilen.
Aber dass gerade die Kirche häufig
in dieser Beantwortung dieser Frage immer
noch ein religiöser Hintergrund ist,
das ist doch quasi wirklich absurd. Gerade
in Bundesländern, wo ich weiß gar
nicht, der Anteil der Kirche, es ist
eine Minderheit, dass die da noch
mitredet, finde ich eher schwierig.
Der Anteil der Kirche ist eine Sache.
Ich bin auch nicht in der Kirche und trotzdem
rede ich mit so vielen
Leuten gerade über das Thema.
Ich verstehe alle drei Perspektiven.
Was mir dabei fehlt, ist die Bestimmung über
andere Menschen. Und da kriege ich die Bauchschmerzen.
Niemand von uns sechs,
die hier stehen, hat das Recht
jemanden zu sagen: Dein Wunsch zu sterben,
zählt nicht. Natürlich hab ich das Recht,
ihm Hilfsangeboten zu geben. Aber nicht
umsonst ist die Suizidrate gerade im Medizinbereich
relativ hoch, wo Menschen
arbeiten, die wissen wie Sachen am Ende
ausgehen. Und ich glaube, diese Gewalt
zu verhindern, gegen sich selbst und gegen seine Mitmenschen,
das ist für mich
ein Hauptgrund, weswegen ich hier
stehe und sage: Bitte lasst es zu und lasst uns
nach einem Weg suchen wie Menschen,
die alle Möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft haben,
-friedlich sterben dürfen.
-Ich finde, es ist immer ein bisschen das
Prinzip wie wenn der Laptop
kaputt geht und man schmeisst ihn halt weg.
Heutzutage ist es halt so, früher hat
man die Sachen repariert. Das ist jetzt ganz
-böse gesagt.
-Das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was
-ich gesagt habe.
-Es ist mittlerweile ja schon der Gedanke
-irgendwie so da.
-Nee, es ist genau das Gegenteil. Wenn alle
Möglichkeiten ausgeschöpft sind,
also natürlich bei der Krebsforschung
die Fortschritte sind immens in den letzten
Jahren. Ich habe in meiner Arbeit
ALS-Patienten begleiten dürfen und müssen.
Und zu sehen, wie die wirklich,
also selbst mit palliativer Betreuung
ist das zumindest für mich eine Erkrankung,
die viel, viel Leid mit sich
bringt. Selbst mit einer guten medikamentösen
Einstellung, die ersticken
einfach irgendwann.
Eric, ich muss euch leider kurz
unterbrechen. Da würde ich gleich direkt
zu dir kommen, Benedikt. Du
hast dich nämlich dafür eingesetzt,
dass auch Ärztinnen erlaubt wird,
Menschen bei einem Sterben zu helfen.
Unter welchen Voraussetzungen
würdest du das denn bei einem Patienten
-oder einer Patientin machen?
-Ja, ich bin in der Palliativmedizin tätig
und das ist eigentlich ein Lebenshilfeverein.
Aber ich möchte
auch nicht mit Strafe rechnen müssen,
wenn ich in Einzelfällen bereit bin, diesen Weg
mitzugehen. Ich werde immer
versuchen, Patienten, die mit einem Wunsch
nach Sterbehilfe zu mir
kommen, die Menschen im Leben zu halten
und sie zu begleiten und den natürlichen
Krankheitsverlauf zuzulassen. Aber es gibt
Situationen, in denen kann ich nachvollziehen,
das Menschen den Weg
bis zum Ende dieser Krankheit nicht
gehen müssen. Und ich möchte mich einem solchen
-Wunsch nicht verschließen.
-Du hast gerade "strafbar" gesagt, also
dass du dich nicht strafbar machen
möchtest und dass andere Ärzt_innen sich
nicht strafbar machen möchten. Gab es denn
mal diese Situation, dass du einen Patient
oder eine Patientin hattest und du
gemerkt hast, wenn es jetzt möglich wäre,
dann wäre das die bessere Möglichkeit
für diese Situation gewesen? Oder der Patient,
die Patientin hat
sich das total gewünscht?
Ich bin ausdrücklich kein
Sterbehelfer. Das ist einfach auf meine berufliche
Situation bezogen, in der ich auch unausweichlich,
weil das ja
meine Patienten sind, mich damit
beschäftigen muss. Und das würde ich eben
gerne in den Beratungsgesprächen
ergebnisoffen machen können.
Und wenn ich der Auffassung
bin, dass das eine eben wohl erwogene
und freiverantwortete Entscheidung
ist, ohne auch Druck von außen. Und das können
wir, glaube ich, beurteilen, wenn wir die Patienten
eng betreuen, wir kennen dann
auch das Umfeld, dann für mich zu entscheiden:
Ja, das kann ich mitgehen.
-Gab's da mal eine konkrete Situation?
-Ja, natürlich gab es das und es gab auch
eine Situation, dass ich jemanden
weggeschickt habe, weil ich mir nicht
-sicher war, wie das weitergeht.
-Wie steht ihr denn zu dem, was Benedikt
jetzt gerade gesagt hat? Bewegt
euch das irgendwie nach vorne oder?
Er hat natürlich Recht, aber er hat
natürlich Unrecht, wenn er suggeriert,
dass es verboten sei oder gewesen
wäre, auch zu 217. Wenn man die Begründung
zu dem Paragraph gelesen hat,
steht ja eindeutig drin, dass Nahestehende,
womit die Ärzte, die nahestehend
sind, auch gemeint waren. Es hat nicht
ein einziges Verfahren mit 217 in den fünf
Jahren gegeben. Und auch seit es überhaupt
Berufsrecht gibt oder wie auch immer
in Deutschland, noch nie ist ein Arzt
in irgendeiner Form belangt worden
wegen unzulässiger Form der Sterbehilfe. Da gibt
es nicht einen einzigen Fall.
Aber spätestens jetzt hast du doch alle
Freiheiten, Menschen beim Suizid zu begleiten,
so wie es jeder andere Mensch
auch kann. Eben nicht nur Ärzte, die vielleicht
auch nicht immer die Richtigen
sind, um das herauszufinden, ob der Sterbewunsch
ernsthaft ist. Aber du kannst
-es tun.
-Da sind wir ganz beieinander. Und ich habe
eben auch andere Informationen und andere
Auskünfte, dass die Zeit 2015 bis 20 eben
nicht so gefahrlos gewesen ist
oder wäre für uns Ärzte. Und natürlich war
es bis 2015
straffrei. Klar, ich stimme dir zu.
Geht es nicht auch ein bisschen
darum, ob es ein langer, qualvoller Tod ist
oder ob man sich davon
vielleicht erlösen kann, Benedikt?
Einen langsamen, qualvollen Tod, den muss
es ohnehin nicht geben. Da wird schlechte
Medizin betrieben, unbarmherzige,
schlechte und wahrscheinlich inkompetente
Medizin. Wenn Menschen in sterbensnaher
Situation - da wird immer
von Kot-Erbrechen gesprochen, da wird
von schwerster Luftnot gesprochen - wenn man
die nicht vernünftig behandelt, dann
macht man sich ja strafbar. Denn das kann man.
Das konnte man auch vor 20, 30, 40
Jahren schon, wenn man sich ein bisschen
mit Medikamenten auskennt und auch weiß,
dass man sehr hochdosiert auch Medikamente
geben darf, die das Bewusstsein zum Erlöschen
bringen und auch in Kauf nimmt,
dass die Menschen dann eher
sterben. Aber das ist eben nicht das Problem,
weswegen ich hier stehe. Das Problem
ist nicht sterbensnah und leidvoll,
-sondern sterbensfern und leidensfrei.
-Ich finde, man redet immer so viel drüber,
kann ich den Selbstmord möglichst schmerzfrei
machen oder sowas. Ich finde,
es sollte viel mehr Wert darauf gelegt
werden, den zu verhindern. Weil ich finde
es krass, dass ich mit meiner
Geschichte alleine schon, ich kann es aufzählen,
wie viele Leute schon zu mir
gekommen sind und gesagt haben: Wegen dir,
weil ich sehe, dass du doch in einer schwierigen
Situation, in einer leidvollen
Situation sogar noch glücklich
leben kannst. Deswegen möchte ich mich nicht
mehr umbringen und das finde ich halt
richtig krass, wenn ich sowas höre,
dann denke ich, dann sind die ganzen
Gesetzesentwürfe eigentlich mal
Nebensache. Man sollte eher mal
vielleicht sich darauf fokussieren, wie kann man
auch psychologisch oder eben über
den Glauben oder wie auch immer Leute
vom Selbstmord abbringen. Ich würde
nicht abstreiten, dass das nicht schön ist,
wenn sich jemand von Zug wirft. Ja,
ein Kumpel von mir arbeitet bei der Bahn,
das sollte auf jeden Fall verhindert
werden. Aber nicht in dem Sinne, dass man
sagt: Okay, ich komme zu dir nach Hause
und geb dir die Spritze, sondern indem man
komplett das Problem angeht. Das ist
so eine Ursachenbekämpfung irgendwie.
Ich finde, man sollte
eher das Problem angehen.
Also bei dem möchte ich mich
gerne anschließen, weil ich kenne selbst
Depressionen, Angststörungen. Ich kenne
viele andere Betroffene. Ich selbst kenne
Menschen, die durch den Suizid
gestorben sind. Und ich kenne auch selbst
Suizidgedanken bzw. auch einen
Suizidversuch. Ich bin
gegen die Sterbehilfe, vor allem
bei psychischen Erkrankungen,
weil ich überzeugt davon bin,
dass wir die Möglichkeiten der Prävention
als auch der Behandlungen noch nicht
vollkommen ausgereizt haben. Wir sollten
viel mehr Energie, Zeit, Geld, was auch immer
in die Prävention und die Behandlung
von körperlichen wie auch psychischen
Erkrankungen stecken. Anstatt zu sagen:
-Komm her, hier kriegst ne Pille.
-Geht ihr einen Schritt auf Nora zu?
Ich bin jetzt so ein bisschen am Treten
hier, weil ich denke natürlich, da musst
du doch nicht drüber in den Ring
gehen hier. Da sind wir doch alle bei dir.
Das wir gravierende
Defizite haben im Umgang mit Kranken.
Das wird aber nicht thematisiert im Fernsehen
oder sonst wo, es gibt so wenig
Berichte darüber. Sterbehilfe ist so
ein riesiges Thema, dass sich viele auch gar
nicht trauen, vielleicht mal zum Psychologen
zu gehen oder wo auch immer
hinzugehen, sich Hilfe zu holen.
Ich finde, das kriegt viel zu wenig
-Aufmerksamkeit.
-Aber du musst es ergänzen. Es geht ja
weiter. Also ihr sprecht aus medizinischer
Sicht über Angebote. Wenn alle Menschen
mit einer tödlichen Diagnose einen
Hospizplatz in Deutschland in Anspruch
nehmen würden, dann würden die Hospize,
also die haben jetzt zumindest
in den großen Städten überall
Wartelisten. Und dennoch kommt es aber immer wieder
-auf einen Punkt.
-Deswegen können wir keine Sterbehilfe
-anbieten, weil die Hospize voll sind.
-Wenn ich in Kenntnis all dieser Punkte -
ich weiß, ich kann in ein Hospiz
gehen; ich weiß, ich kann von einem guten
Palliativmediziner betreut werden -
immer noch sage: Ich möchte diesen Leidensweg
nicht gehen. Es geht immer um diese Gruppe.
Es geht nicht um Menschen,
wo es verhindert werden kann, weil sie durch
einen guten Psychotherapeuten
gerettet werden, wo man sich über jeden
freut, dem es besser geht. Jede Geschichte
wie deine ist toll, aber es gibt
dennoch Menschen, die sterben an ihren
Erkrankungen und wollen auf diese Art
und Weise nicht sterben.
Aber er hat ja vor allem von sterbensferner
Sterbehilfe geredet,
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Das heißt, dass der Tod eigentlich noch gar
nicht so nahe ist und man vorher
ausscheiden will. Und das ist dann bei mir
dieser Gedanke, die Angst vor dem Leid
kann oft größer sein als das Leid selber.
Nora, warum sagst du denn,
dass es für dich fatal gewesen wäre,
wenn zu dem Zeitpunkt es schon
möglich gewesen wäre, Sterbehilfe in Anspruch
-zu nehmen?
-Aus dem ganz einfachen Grund, dass ich
inzwischen zu mir und meinem Leben
gefunden habe. Ich bin glücklich in meinem
Leben. Ich bin stärker aus der Krise
herausgetreten und könnte das alles nicht
erleben, wenn ich damals
die Pille genommen hätte.
Wenn du sie Anspruch hättest
nehmen können, dann hättest du es gemacht?
Auf jeden Fall. Und ich habe spontan
im Vorfeld auf Instagram meine Community
gefragt, einfach mal so: Mensch, wenn ihr vor ein paar
Jahren in einer depressiven
Krise die Chance gehabt
hättet auf assistierten Suizid, hättet
ihr das gemacht? Und wenn ihr aber
heute noch lebt, seid ihr froh, dass es damals
die Möglichkeit noch nicht gab? Und zwei
Drittel der Befragten haben gesagt,
sie hätten das wahrgenommen. Sie sind
aber heute froh, dass es die Möglichkeit nicht
gab. Und das finde ich wichtig zu sehen.
Na klar gibt es auch das andere Drittel,
die gesagt hätten: So ja, ich hab's
gemacht und ich finde es blöd,
dass es damals die Möglichkeit noch
nicht gab. Ich möchte auch, ich verurteile
keinen Menschen, der Suizid begeht.
Fänd's auch total falsch, wenn das wie früher
unter Strafe stehen würde. Ich finde
das aber falsch, das geschäftsmäßig zu machen.
Könnt ihr ihr da zustimmen, versteht
ihr ihren Punkt.?Dann könnt ihr einen Schritt
-auf sie zugehen.
-Ja, es ist natürlich die schwerste
Situation, die es zu beurteilen gilt,
ob sie freiverantwortlich ist, ob sie wohl
überlegt ist. Du sprachst von der depressiven
Krise. Wer in der Lage ist,
das zu erkennen, der wird natürlich
einen solchen Weg nicht mitgehen und er dürfte
ihn auch nicht mitgehen. Weil wir die Freiverantwortung
brauchen,
das Wohlüberlegte und die Nachhaltigkeit.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob man
da grundsätzlich sagen darf:
Nein, psychiatrische Diagnose schließt
Suizidassistenz aus. Auch da gibt
es einen Leidensweg, ständig Medikamente
einzunehmen und trotzdem
natürlich immer wieder mal einzubrechen.
Ich würde gerne dazu sagen, ich hatte
nicht eine einmalige depressive Krise,
sondern seit meiner Kindheit. Ich war
mehrmals in ambulanter Therapie,
in Tageskliniken mehrmals, in einer Psychiatrie.
Ich habe verschiedene
Antidepressiva genommen. Ich bin seit
vier Jahren stabil. Ich bin jetzt 36, mit 32
Jahren hatte ich so für mich den Weg.
Aber seit meiner Kindheit kenne
ich die Symptomatiken. Dazu
auch generalisierte Angststörung
mit Panikattacken. Es gibt Phasen in meinem
Leben, da konnte ich nicht alleine
einkaufen gehen, S-Bahn fahren oder was auch immer.
Und war auf die Unterstützung
meines Partners oder Freund_
innen angewiesen.
Aber zum Beispiel jetzt sagst
du, bist du vier Jahre lang stabil.
-Ja.
-Du würdest ja von dir behaupten, dass du
in der Lage bist,
freiverantwortlich, einen Willen zu formulieren. Und dann
hättest du die Möglichkeit, dann
doch diesen Schritt zu gehen, um vielleicht
nicht in weitere Krisen zu gelangen.
Wie ich das bewerte, dass sich
da auch massivste Bauchschmerzen
bei hätte, ist völlig unbenommen. Aber
die Rechtslage ist nun mal so, dass man
das dann dürfte und ich glaube eben nicht,
dass man aufgrund deiner
psychiatrischen Diagnose dir dieses Recht vorenthalten
-sollte.
-Das finde ich jetzt eine krasse Aussage.
Also jetzt mal auf Deutsch gesagt:
Du sollst dich jetzt entscheiden können,
nur weil du eventuell wieder
Depressionen kriegen könntest, dich jetzt umzubringen.
Ich hab die Veranlagung. Also ich hatte
die rezidivierende, zu gut Deutsch kann
man auch chronisch sagen,
Depression. Und ich weiß, dass ich gefährdet bin,
dass ich besonders auf mich achten
muss, wenn es irgendwelche Schicksalsschläge
gibt, sage ich mal. Aber jetzt zu entscheiden,
"ach Mensch, in drei Jahren
könnte wieder eine Krise kommen" und "ach
nee, da lieber sterbe ich lieber gleich",
wo kommen wir da hin, wenn wir so
handeln? Das finde ich einfach total unethisch.
-Brigitte, verstehst du diesen einen Punkt?
-Ich denke, bei Depressiven ist es nochmal
eine andere Sache. Wie man da sicherstellen
kann, dass es eine wirkliche
Entscheidung von innen heraus ist und dass er zurechnungsfähig
ist. Das ist anders,
als wenn jemand wirklich aus dem Innersten
heraus zurechnungsfähig entscheidet:
Ich möchte nicht mehr leben. Ich denke,
wer da psychische Probleme hat, den muss
man schon mehr beschützen, sag ich mal
so. Also dem würde ich jetzt nicht für nächste
Woche einen Termin geben
und sagen: Okay, wir machen das.
Dann könnte dir eigentlich ein Schritt
auf sie zugehen, weil ich glaube, ihr seht
-das auch so.
-Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, ich finde es
schwierig, dass wir psychische
Krankheiten anders bewerten als körperliche,
weil wir sagen, dann können sie nicht
mehr entscheiden. Ein psychisch Kranker darf
auch zu einer Operation einwilligen.
Also ich bin da ein bisschen bei dir. Ich finde
es schwierig, das zu unterscheiden.
Und ich finde auch, dass wir Menschen
mit psychischen Erkrankungen nicht
Rechte absprechen dürfen, die andere haben.
Das merkt man ja, wenn ich sage "mein
Sohn hat eine Hüft-Op", dann gucken mich alle
an und haben Mitleid. Wenn du sagst,
da war eine psychische Erkrankung, dann ist
die Stimmung erst einmal anders. Also
wir gehen gesellschaftlich mit psychischen
Erkrankungen fürchterlich um und deswegen glaube
ich, können wir da keine
-Unterschiede machen.
-Was denkt ihr den, sollten auch Menschen
mit psychischen Erkrankungen
Sterbehilfe in Anspruch nehmen können oder eher nicht?
Wir kommen jetzt zur Kompromissrunde,
damit ihr bestenfalls gleich alle hier
steht und euch in einigen Punkten
einig seid und gemeinsam Lösungen findet.
Ich habe jetzt erst einmal einen
Lösungsvorschlag für euch. Können wir uns
darauf einigen, dass wir offizielle
und vom Staat kontrollierte Beratungsstellen
brauchen, die mithilfe
von Ärzt_innen, Psycholog_innen,
Sozialarbeiter_innen entscheiden,
wer Beihilfe zum Suizid nehmen darf und wer
nicht? Wenn ihr sagt "ja", dann könnt
ihr einen Schritt auf mich zukommen. Ihr habt
-euch gar nicht bewegt.
-Nein, weil es eigentlich gar nicht die
Frage sein sollte, ob diese Option
da ist. Ich habe auch immer wieder gehört,
dieser Punkt, dass es schlimm
ist, bei Angehörigen Suizid mitzuerleben.
Ich glaube, dass genau diese Schuldgefühle
auch da sein können,
wenn das selbstbestimmt passiert. Und ich glaube,
dass man da irgendwie, Suizid ist
-einfach keine Lösung.
-Dann habt ihr jetzt die Möglichkeit, euch
gegenseitig nochmal zu überzeugen,
weil das ist ja hier ein bisschen das Ziel.
Ihr könnt euch jetzt jeweils,
beide Seiten, für eine Minute die Köpfe
zusammenstecken und überlegen: Was wäre
ein Vorschlag, ein Lösungsvorschlag
-für euch beide?
-Wo wir uns einig sind
Okay, wir haben jetzt nach dieser Diskussion
gemerkt, es ist gar nicht so
einfach, dieses ganze Thema um Sterbehilfe
zu lösen. Also falls ihr jetzt einen
Kompromissvorschlag habt, den ihr gerne
hier genau jetzt vorschlagen würdet,
-dann schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
-Aber da haben wir nur Unterschiede.
-Na ja, so ähnlich.
-Das klingt hervorragend.
Wollt ihr anfangen, habt
ihr einen Lösungsvorschlag?
-Es ist bisschen schwierig.
-Also zumindest erstmal ist es ein Ansatz,
zu einer Lösung zu kommen. Wir haben
gefunden, dass wir eine Diskussion,
eine breite gesellschaftliche
Diskussion von Kindergarten über Arbeitsplatz
bis sonst wohin brauchen zu diesen Themen.
Ohne diese Polarität in die religiös
Vernagelten und die wild
absurd Freiheitdenken.
Dass wir von diesem Schwarz-Weiß
wegkommen müssen, um zu einem Weg zu kommen.
-Würdet ihr da zustimmen?
-Ich würde zustimmen, dass wir sagen,
niemand, der mit der Thematik
verbunden ist, der angesprochen wird, hat
auch den Wunsch, dass dieser Sterbewunsch
nicht realisiert,
sondern dass wir natürlich alle
zwar vielleicht ergebnisoffen, aber doch
von der Intention her das Ziel haben,
dass der Mensch sich nicht umbringt. Das ist
-doch, glaube ich, Konsens für alle.
-Aber dann könnt ihr ja eigentlich jetzt
wirklich alle einen
Schritt aufeinander zugehen.
Nein, weil das einfach nicht stimmt,
dass das niemand will. Du nicht und keiner
hier, aber es gibt auch andere
Leute. Das hat ja was mit Macht zu tun, andere
zum Tod zu führen. Das sind ja auch alles
Leute, die psychologisch manchmal selber
-Hilfe brauchen.
-Aber ich glaube, das sind jetzt keine
Größenordnungen, über die man sich
jetzt hier Gedanken machen muss. Ich glaube,
eine Sterbehilfe Vereinigungen, damit
habe ich auch meine Schwierigkeiten. Es sollte
eine gute und natürlich auch kostenlose
Möglichkeit geben und niedrigschwellige
Möglichkeit geben, sich
Beratung zu holen auf ganz vielen Ebenen.
-Das ist jetzt euer Vorschlag?
-Genau.
-Okay.
-Man kann das auch nicht so verkürzen auf
eine Minute, so ein Riesenproblem, das wir jetzt
mit einem klaren Urteil, mit einem
weit reichenden Urteil haben, jetzt
in die Praxis umzusetzen. Das geht einfach
in diesen zwei Minuten jetzt so nicht.
Aber ich denke, uns verbindet, glaube ich,
die Intention, dass wir möglichst versuchen,
die Menschen im Leben
-zu halten.
-Das würde ich auf jeden Fall zustimmen.
Dann könnt ihr einen
Schritt aufeinander zugehen.
Ich glaube, es ist eine viel
größere Sache. Es muss in was viel größeres
eingebunden sein und das haben wir ja
kurz angesprochen. Ausbau der Hospize,
Beratung et cetera et cetera. Die Gesellschaft
muss auch lernen, anders
mit dem Tod umzugehen. Nicht immer nur als Feind
anzuschauen, sondern als Baustein
des Lebens, als letzten Baustein
des Lebens, der das Leben dann abrundet,
-der den Kreislauf des Lebens schließt.
-Da stimme ich voll zu. Also gerade in der
jungen Generation, dass so wenig über
den Tod überhaupt nachgedacht wird. Und dann,
wenn es eben mal soweit ist, dann muss
man ganz schnell eine Entscheidung treffen.
Und sich da bewusst zu sein, jeder
Tag könnte der letzte sein, auch heute.
Wir wissen es ja nicht genau. Und am Ende
hat man es eben nicht in der Hand.
In manchen Fällen kann man es vielleicht
sagen, aber das fände ich voll schön,
wenn das in der Gesellschaft auch ein bisschen
thematisiert wird und da einfach
offen darüber diskutiert wird.
Und das fand ich heute voll schön.
-Genau. Ich auch.
-Ich danke euch auf jeden Fall für die
Diskussion. Es hat mich sehr gefreut.
Es war sehr spannend. Danke euch. Ja,
-war schön.
-Dankeschön.
Was soll man sagen nach so einer Diskussion?
Ich glaube, wir alle haben
heute nochmal gelernt, wie emotional
und sensibel und individuell dieses Thema ist
und gerade durch diese individuellen
persönlichen Geschichten merkt man dann
auch nochmal, wie schwer es ist,
wirklich eine Regelung dafür in der Zukunft
zu finden, weil eben bei jedem die Probleme
und die Geschichte anders ist.
Haben euch Argumente überzeugt?
Vielleicht denkt ihr jetzt sogar anders über
das Thema, ist nicht selten so
bei 13 Fragen. Dann schreibt es gerne
in die Kommentare und ansonsten
lasst gerne ein Abo da. Das könnt ihr hier
machen. Hier oben findet ihr ein weiteres
Video von 13 Fragen und hier ein weiteres
Video zum Thema.